du côté de québec maintenant ça fait
plusieurs mois qu'on en parle ce sera
finalement jeudi que le premier ministre
philippe couillard va procéder à un
remaniement de son conseil des ministres
près de deux ans après l'élection de son
gouvernement alors sébastien
commençons par parler de l'ampleur est
ce qu'il faut s'attendre à de gros
changements
céline essayer de répondre à cette
question à cette heure ci précise c'est
un peu comme essayer de prédire l'avenir
en lisant des feuilles de thé est
simplement un nombre très restreint de
personnes qui connaissent les véritables
intentions de philippe couillard au
moment où on pense pas sauf que ce soir
on a des indices on laisse entendre que
le remaniement ministériel sera d'une
certaine ampleur qu'il sera frappée d'un
mot clé le dynamisme qui aura une
philosophie de vouloir tourner ou de
vouloir écrire un nouveau chapitre du
mandat du gouvernement de philippe
couillard et un constat aussi le constat
que ça va pas si mal pour le parti
libéral actuellement en particulier dans
les sondages alors si vous prenez tous
ces indices que vous les mettez dans une
casserole que vous faites mijoter on
peut s'attendre à un jeu de chaises
musicales relativement important au sein
du conseil des ministres c'est à dire
que des ministres déjà en poste vont
rester au conseil des ministres
mais peut-être dans des fonctions
différentes et on doit s'attendre aussi
à l'arrivée de quelques nouveaux visages
des députés qui pourrait être donc promu
au sein du conseil des ministres alors
un remaniement c'est toujours un
exercice y fait des heureux et des
malheureux qui risque d'être rétrogradé
on va commencer avec cela alors comment
sont perçus qui sont sur la corde raide
en effet david heurtel ministre de
l'environnement en ce sens et par
philippe couillard la fin de l'année
pour sa performance sur la scène
internationale mais qui a connu une
année 2015 disons plutôt difficile dans
la gestion du ministère de
l'environnement
il y à aussi francine charbonneau la
ministre de la famille qui a beaucoup de
difficulté à expliquer les compressions
dans le réseau des garderies et jacques
daoud ça faudra voir mais disons qu'il
est peut être victime des attentes qui
étaient placés en lui
pour stimuler l'économie il n'a pas
toujours été à la hauteur de ses
attentes lors des premiers mois du
mandat du gouvernement couillard oui
certains évoqué le midi ducation
françois blais je ne vois pas son votre
liste
mes feuilles de thé me dise qu'il
devrait rester à son poste d'autant
qu'il a entrepris une grande réforme des
commissions scolaires
alors écoutez il n'y a pas de science
exacte mais
l'impression qu'il va rester en poste on
aura peut-être une surprise jeudi
alors les autres qui sont pressentis
pour accepter accéder au cabinet
philippe couillard avait dit plus de
femmes plus de jeunes plus de
représentants des régions
oui ce sont des critères qui l'a énoncé
évidemment le premier critère c'est la
compétence alors dominique anglade qui
est une député fraîchement élu a
certainement la compétence pour devenir
ministre
son handicap son principal handicap ce
qu'il vient directement de la coalition
avenir québec julie boulet a
l'expérience ministérielle
son avantage c'est qu'elle vient d'une
région c'est à dire la mort ici il y a
peut être une carte cachée qui est
monique sauvé élu député dans la région
de laval
si francine charbonneau qui est aussi
une députée de laval quitte le conseil
des ministres
madame souris pourrait la remplacer
comme représentante de la région de
laval
évidemment véronique tremblay qui a
impressionné philippe couillard en
gagnant la circonscription de chauveau
aux mains de la coalition avenir québec
son handicap c'est peut-être qu'il y a
déjà deux ministres dans la région de
québec françois blais s'il reste en
poste est également sam hamad est ce que
la région québec peut avoir trois
ministres c'est un pensez-y-bien pour
monsieur couillard en terminant un mot
sur l'iss thériault on me laisse
entendre que madame thériault sera du
conseil des ministres avec des tâches
peut être moins lourde et qu'elle
devrait être sur place pour le
remaniement ministériel de jeudi donc
elle serait de retour très bien merci
beaucoup
sébastien annoncé jeudi 10 heures on va
surveiller ça salon voilà exact merci
sébastien aubin